hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich reagiere heute auf die hilf
mir Episode bauer sucht Barbie
[Musik]
warum ist er nackt
er gibt absolut gar keinen Sinn
warum ist der nackt und das ist deine
Freundin oder wie warum fährt er
überhaupt mit zum Ding darum
also er gibt also genau
[Musik]
er Kuhstall das gehört sich so mein
neues Parfum
[Musik]
men
okay
oder was warum ist vorne am Traktor
überhaupt so Blumen Unkraut Scheiße dran
wahrscheinlich nicht
[Musik]
den Rest das ist kein Problem
Moment
er sagt das müssen wir irgendwo
verstecken auf dem Land klaut keiner nix
doch gar keinen Sinn wenn keiner was
klaut dann brauchst du auch nicht
verstecken aber in erster Linie stellt
sich mir einfach nur die Frage wenn er
doch eh schon nicht alles mitkriegt mit
dem Traktor warum kommt er nicht direkt
mit dem Jeep
will ein bisschen angeben mit diesem
Ding
ja die Louis weltentasche oder ab ins
gebüscht das ist der Fabio
wie kann man sich denn einem Satz
dreimal versprechen als Schauspieler
en Schuhen
ich dachte das wäre Erde hier bei ihm
dran aber das sind Tattoos ne
oh wir kommen
ich habe ihn vor zwei Wochen auf einer
Party kennengelernt das war einfach
Schicksal endlich mal jemand der kein
Arschloch ist und jetzt sehe ich zu ihm
auf dem Bauernhof das wird bestimmt
super romantisch
[Musik]
auf dem Bauernhof stell dich doch nicht
anders
wer bist du denn ist das deine
Angestellte so gucken
ältere Leute voll auf die gucken dann
erstmal so
okay die kommen ja auch immer so ein
Zentimeter zu nah deine Angestellte
Angestellter ist meine Mutter Gießen da
hallo
chillig einfach doppelt ah Hilfe ich
liebe euch komplette Folge ist übrigens
unten in der Beschreibung verlinkt falls
ihr euch die komplett anschauen möchtet
wann das möchte du bist doch jetzt hier
um uns zu helfen ja wir haben doch keine
angestellt wir sind hier im Bauernhof
und dann ist Köln das ist schön das hört
man direkt
also ich bin Mimi ich komme aus Köln und
ich habe gesagt ich habe es gemacht
liebelein ganz ruhig hier ja zum
Kaffeeklatsch haben wir hier ja keine
Zeit du musst jetzt hier mal den Stall
ausmisten und die Kühe melken der zeigt
der Bändiger die Hühner müssen die
füttert werden
das ist doch nicht Köln die Oma oder
Mutter ist 100 % ich Gönnerin die redet
eins zu eins wie so urkellner komm wir
müssen erstmal die Hühner füttern müsste
mal die Kühe melken ich kann das nicht
so gut aber das merkst du das hat der
richtige Kölnerin ist aber wo sind denn
solche Bauernhöfe in Köln what the [__]
nee nee
Soundtrack irgendwie
sind bei diesen hilf mir
Zusammenfassungen auf Youtube von den
ganzen Folgen die es ja irgendwo in der
Mediathek gibt nie die Kommentare von
den Moderatoren drin diesen
Zwischensequenzen die ganzen Musik kommt
deswegen werde ich die jetzt einfach mal
nachstellen Mutter Gisela ist bisher
alles andere als begeistert von Mimi der
neuen Freundin ihres Sohnes Ben die
beiden Faulenzer liegen noch im Bett
obwohl es schon 10 Uhr ist zu dieser
Uhrzeit mussten schon längst die Kühe
junge Mann hast du nicht auf Tour
geguckt wie viel Uhr
[Musik]
ey die mimi ist wahrscheinlich so einer
die hat ihren Friseurladen oder ihr
Nagelstudio oder irgendwas in Köln hatte
hier entspanntes Leben gesehen und macht
der Laden auf komm sag mal sagen wir 11
Uhr macht der Laden auf sie steht ganz
entspannt um 10:30 Uhr auf packt sie
rein in den Jogger und setzt sich dahin
ein bisschen erstmal tiktok chillen
Alter da kommt diese laufen Bauernhof um
6:30 Uhr
[Applaus]
ich kann nicht alles alleine
Mikrofon und Kopfhörer auf tätowiert
deutschland sucht den Bauer Star Wars
Thema nein
schöner schlaf schön
Mama wir
sind immer wenn sie Bauernhof sagt bitte
im Schott trinken ich will jetzt auch
nicht wieder hier die ganze Einrichtung
hätten aber die Tapete hier
moment mal
wirst du bestimmt nicht bei haben ne oh
mein Gott
Gummistiefel
boah ich habe Gummistiefel so gehasst
ich spiele doch lieber Fußball oder
kletter rum anstatt dass sich in Match
bringen also was ist daran so cool warum
feiern das so viele Kinder eine schöne
Anzug und balleckere Stiefel der ganze
hast du sowas leckeres mit drin mit
deinem Barbie Klamotten da lachen sich
ja die Kühe im Stall kaputt
[Musik]
fünf Minuten ich habe meine Hand kaputt
ne zack jetzt hier
hat manchmal wünschte ich mir aber dass
ich hier zu Hause in meiner Kölner
Wohnung wo ich alleine lebe sondern
Personen hätte die dann wirklich sagt
komm jetzt aufstehen wenn man
selbstständig arbeitet das hat ganz ganz
viele Vorteile aber man muss halt selber
den inneren Schweinehund besiegen weil
wenn man nicht arbeitet verdient man
auch nichts weißt du wie ich meine dass
er mich sehr krass an diese Situation
früher zu Hause wenn man so ich hatte
mal Wecker auf 6:30 Uhr glaube ich wenn
meine Mutter mich dann geweckt hat um
6:35 Uhr wieder eingeschlafen wenn sie
so das war fünf Minuten dann kommst Du
heraus oder wusste genau wenn ich diese
fünf Minuten überschreite dann ist aber
wirklich da wirst du beim vor und
Nachnamen angesprochen und ihr wisst das
mit eure Eltern euch beim Vor- und
Nachnamen oder sagen wir haben einen
zweiten vor und Zweitname wenn meine
Eltern zu mir angekommen meine Mom
beispielsweise morgens immer mein Papa
war selber ein bisschen Langschläfer
wenn meine Mom immer dann so ankommen
gar nichts mehr aber gut ich habe hier
tatsächlich gerade nicht mehr auf die
Hälfte drauf reagiert aber es war schon
lacht deswegen wenn ihr einen zweiten
Teil möchte wo ich auf dem Rest darauf
reagiere
[Musik]